[Music]
love Simon
to love Simon is a coming-of-age story
about Simon he has a solid family
structure has his friends in high school
he seems relatively like the Simon's gay
and nobody knows that then he reads a
blog and then becomes pen pals with
someone else from a school who is also
gay nobody knows who he is so they
become anonymous pen pals all the while
he's just trying to figure out what to
do here and what we have here is a very
effective coming-of-age story that I
really enjoyed I think adored is the
word I adored this [ __ ] out of his movie
the main one they have to play Simon I
love that hold on I imagine I've seen
him somewhere in movies before I just I
just can't think of him Nick Robinson
yeah he's been a lot of stuff but this
is the breakout role like when I see him
again I'll be like oh that's Nick
Robinson from love Simon he's just so
charismatic as an actor but also so
loveable it's so easy to project
yourself into his situation I mean not
the situation having to come out as a
gay person because I haven't I haven't
had that that's what I love about this
movie it's just one thing about Simon
yeah the plot generally revolves around
Simon building the courage to come out
at the very least revolves around his
secret of being gay that nobody knows
but if I'm to make an observation a lot
of times in movies if there is a gay
character their entire character is the
fact that they are gay it's like we have
a gay character cuz we need a gay
character how deep is the character were
you not listening they're gay but that's
not a deep character you see people are
more than their sexual preference or
sexuality this movie better than most
properly illustrates that for an
effective coming-of-age story it's just
very important to have the audience
project themselves into it even if
they're well past high school watching
this movie should take them back to high
school in some fashion and this movie
completely does that I love that the
supporting cast was fantastic to
Jennifer Garner and Josh Duhamel not
only were they important because just
look at them you're like yeah you got
that put together house don't you have
white picket fence going on but the
important thing they bring to the table
is that in a world where it's a movie
about a kid coming out how do his
parents handle it how do his friends
handle it how do people handle it I
adored his friends but at one point I
just felt like they were overreacting a
bit over something I was like you guys
are kind of making this all about you
and you're kind of being Dexter right
now overreacting is the word I used in
my head then I just realized whoa
they're teenagers they're supposed to
overreact yeah any teenagers watching
this if your mom or your parent or an
adult is coming at you just be like I'm
a kid I'm supposed to overreact
I imagine any adult who hears a kid say
that will be like
probably self-aware yet one of those any
more than that it'll start to wear and
there's one character that hangs out
with them I didn't like him at all I
know you're not really supposed to love
him in the movie but I just felt like he
went so far it he he was a bit
unredeemable for me I get it was to
drive the plot forward and he did his
part for the plot movie didn't do a good
enough job at redeeming him if they ever
needed to redeem him special shout out
to the drama t-shirt we're talking scene
stealer any scene with the drama teacher
she's the only one you know she's
amazing she's fantastic again don't know
what I've seen her in because I'm [ __ ]
with phases apparently but I do want to
see her more stuff guys in the end love
Simon I truly loved loved Simon it's a
movie that's set out to do certain
things and I personally feel it
succeeded in although this is the best
coming-of-age story since age of 17 that
I've personally saying I haven't seen
all of them I get that but it's my
favorite sense this movie can and will
connect with anyone who has ever been
searching for love in their life
especially in high school it may connect
more with some people on a deeper and
personal level that's the beauty of
cinema but this movie's not walled off
to anybody it's a movie for everybody
and I will say love Simon is definitely
worth watching and definitely worth
buying on blu-ray
alright so love Simon have you seen it
what did you think about it I'm filming
this on Saturday so I don't know how
many people watch the movie at this
point hope a lot did what's your
favorite coming-of-age story whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]